[Music]
Newt Gingrich's campaign having a little
bit of money trouble if you heard about
this Newt Gingrich's campaign is now
charging people 50 dollars to pose for a
picture with Newt yeah yeah and for a
hundred dollars you can get one without
Newt the Supreme Court is deciding right
now whether the government can mandate
that all Americans buy health insurance
yep when he heard this Rick Santorum
said there's no way I'm letting the
government make me go on a mandate
if everyone's Scarlett Johansson got her
cell phone hacked well the man who
hacked into Scarlett Johansson's cell
phone and posted nude photos of her has
pled guilty that's right
whoever the judge has agreed to reduce
the man sentence if he saw me swears to
do it again
[Applause]
that's my pervy Conan right there in
Germany this big big story in Germany a
court has ruled that German police are
allowed to racially profile citizens are
allowed yes but don't worry it's Germany
so things shouldn't get out of hand
you guys all use GPS pretty much
everyone uses GPS now well safety
experts now say that more and more car
crashes are being caused by GPS devices
car crashes yeah so think twice the next
time your GPS says turn left here if I
can't have you no one can
we'll die together everyone's talking
about Jersey Shore wonder what's gonna
happen yeah losers of Jersey Shore are
figuring out what to do about the show
now that Snooki is pregnant and the
situation is in rehab
yeah their first step is changing the
title of the show - what the hell did
you think was gonna happen it's a really
good laugh for over here you guys are
great but this person is amazing
or high it could be both or both and
Minnesota a high school student has been
told that he cannot cannot bring a porn
star to his prom on the bright side he
has been given permission to bring her
to career day
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought the joke was okay but I loved
your reaction to he can't bring a porn
star
just call let's get out of here yeah
this isn't the America I want to live in
anymore
hey crazy story check this out a light
bulb from 1912 has been discovered and
get this it still works
now the unused light bulb was found in
Angelina Jolie's refrigerator
doesn't eat a lot you see you won't be
seeing that on television tonight maybe
if you told him she was a fan of antique
appliances you won't be seeing that
either
[Applause]
those are the d-man you will be seeing
all of it
this is the funniest part of the montage
check this out gang
that's what I always do when things take
a side turn in the monologue hey check
this out I'm suddenly a 1920s news boy
they sank the Lusitania actually I
should not sunk well before 1920 there's
a nerd at home right now like
maybe was talking about they raised it
in sunken it yeah yeah thank you pal
won't be seeing that either I know now
we're on a roll
[Laughter]